Today's featured speaker is Greg Valiant.
Gregory Valiant is an assistant professor
in Stanford's computer science department.
Some of his recent projects focus
on designing algorithms for
accurately inferring information
about complex distributions
when given surprisingly little data.
More broadly,
his research interests are in algorithms,
learning, applied probability,
statistics, and evolution.
Prior to joining Stanford, Dr.
Valiant was a postdoc at
the Microsoft Lab in New England.
Which focused on integrating
mathematical and algorithmic
sciences with both the social sciences and
aspects of the biomedical sciences.
He received a PhD from UC Berkeley in
Computer Science and degree from Harvard.
He currently teaches CS 161 design and
analysis of algorithms this
winter quarter at Stanford.
Which is part of our SCPD portfolio
offered to our industry students.
So now,
I'd like to turn the floor over to Greg.
>> Okay, well thanks Stephanie,
and thanks for logging in.
So today I was going to tell you
about a few perspectives on how
to get a surprising amount of
information from a given amount of data.
So, a sort of mindset that underpins
this work is the following question.
So, if you're given some data that's
drawn from a very complex distribution.
So, what do you mean by complex?
Well, maybe it's a very high
dimensional distribution.
Maybe if the distribution with
very large domain or alphabet,
it may be a distribution
over rare genetic mutations.
Or maybe it's a distribution
with very complex dependencies,
such as natural language.
Then, and oftentimes,
even if you have a lot of data,
the empirical distribution
of the data is misleading.
In the case of high
dimensional distributions,
well because of the dimensionality,
you need an enormous amount of data
to kind of fill out
the geometry of the space.
In the case of distributions
over very large domains,
often even when you have lots of data you
still fail to observe some of the domain
elements that do arise with
non-negligible probabilities.
In the case of complex dependencies,
well even when you have lots of data,
sometimes you don't actually see
all of these complex dependencies.
So in these cases,
the empirical distribution of the data
you have is often misleading.
And the basic question is, well,
in this undersampled regime,
can we still recover accurate information
about the underlying distributions?
What can you say about the unseen
portion of the distribution?
Can you say anything about
that domain elements that you
haven't actually observed?
Or in cases where maybe you can't assume
great answers to the above two questions
could you still estimate
the value of collecting more data?
Could you estimate well maybe if I
were to get 10 times more data or
100 times more data I would be
able to answer these questions.
So I want to give two motivations for
this work.
So the first is that even though
today's machine learning systems
are extremely impressive, currently
they still use the data they have
extremely inefficiently to just
to give one concrete data point.
So humans learn to speak after
hearing roughly 50 million words.
So between when you are born and
when you are three or
four or five years old, most people
hear 50 million words spoken to them.
So again, this isn't distinct words.
This is 50 million utterances of words.
And so after hearing these 50 million
words, most children have a good grasp of
grammar, good grasp of semantics and
they basically speak like humans.
In contrast, even the state of the art
natural language processing systems today,
they're fed the entire Wikipedia corpus
over and over and over and over again.
And at the end of the day they still lack
some basic grammatical understanding.
And lack kind of sense of semantics.
Okay, so even though today's machine
learning systems are very, very
impressive, they don't use information
that they have all that efficiently.
The second motivation I wanted to
mention is this apparent paradox that
as the number of datasets
around us have grown and
as the sizes of these datasets have grown,
in fact we are increasingly faced
with this problem of seeing these
under sample distributions.
And in the next five to ten years I think
we're going to start to see many more
advances that are based upon getting
more information from the given data,
getting more information from
the data that we actually have.
So with these motivations in mind, I
wanted to discuss three sort of different
settings that I've been
working on recently.
These three settings will all have
the property that for a given amount of
data even when the empirical
distribution of the data is misleading,
we'll still be able to accurately say
things about the underlying distribution.
So in the first part,
which is sort of a warm up,
we'll consider accepting where there
are lots and lots of people, but
each person only has
a tiny amount of data.
And we'll see that you can leverage
the fact that there are lots and
lots of people to improve your empirical
understanding of each person even
though they only have
a little bit of data.
For the second part of the talk we'll
consider a setting where we have a sample
drawn from a distribution over
an extremely large domain.
That we'll actually be able to accurately
infer the structure of the portion of
the domain that we haven't
seen any samples from.
So we'll actually be able to infer things,
but
the number of unseen domain elements
that arise with different probabilities.
In the last part of the talk,
we'll consider geometric setting.
So we're given data drawn from some
high dimensional distribution.
And we'll see that even when we have too
little data to understand the geometric
structure of the distribution, so
we'll have too little data to say,
these are the big principal
components of the distribution.
We'll be able to describe
what structure is there.
So we'll say, we don't know what
the principle components are but
we know that there are 5
directions of big variants and
50 directions of medium variants and
so on.
So while all three of these settings
are going to be rather different,
and the results will be
different in these settings,
there's a common perspective
that underlies and
enables the algorithms that we'll
see in these different settings.
Okay, so let's start.
So in this first setting,
imagine you have n people, and
think of n as being very large.
And each person has some
hidden parameter p sub i.
Maybe p sub i is the probability that
the i-th person gets the flu each year or
maybe p sub i is the probability that each
person pays their credit card late each
month or changes jobs.
Or maybe p sub i is some biological
traits, though maybe p sub i
is probability that a person has male
versus a female child and so on.
So imagine we have a data set, so we have
lots and lots of people, we have n people.
However, each person we only say, in this
case, observe two flips of their coin,
so we observe two independent random
variables for each person with,
or yes with probability p sub i and
no with probability 1- p sub i.
In this case, what can we hope to
say about each person's probability?
Well, the first thing to observe
is that the empirical estimates
of the p i's are extremely unreliable.
We just have two flips
of each person's coin.
What can we hope to say?
So if we look at the first person,
they flipped their coin twice.
They got two yeses.
The empirical estimate of this
first person's probability is 1.
In both tosses they got yes,
empirical estimate is 1.
And obviously, this is very noisy because
we only have two flips of the coin.
Okay, so in general, if you want to
estimate the bias of a coin to error
epsilon, you do need to flip it roughly
one over epsilon squared times.
It's here we only have two tosses.
What can we hope to say?
Well, suppose we look at all
the data in aggregate, and
we happen to know just
the following phenomenon.
That suppose we see that actually
the number of people who got two yes' is
roughly equal to the number of people who
got two no's, which is equal to the number
of people who got a no and a yes, a yes
and a no, and these are very accurately,
the number of people with each of
these is very close to and over four.
So I claim that based on,
if we work out seamless data,
we can actually conclude that
almost all of these probabilities,
almost all of the pizza buys,
most be extremely close to a half.
So what's the reasoning behind this?
Well, suppose that 10% of the people
had a probability of point six and
10% had a probability of point four and
maybe the rest of the people had
a probability of point five.
Then the theme that we
would actually start to
see a noticeable amount of
correlation in these two flips.
We'd actually see more
people with the yes yes and
more people with the no no then with
the mixed no yes' and yes no's.
So if you think about this a little bit,
if we actually saw data like this,
I claim that we could really conclude
that at least N minus to the two-thirds
of these UPI's are equal to a half plus or
minus maybe 1 over the cube root of N.
And so we can make extremely concrete
statements about this that really
pin down the of p sub i's.
And again, the intuition is that if
this wasn't the case, if there was more
variation between the Pi's, we would have
seen very different summary statistics.
Okay, so this is pretty amazing.
So suppose we solved,
we looked at the aggregate statistics and
saw almost the exact,
n/4 people with each of these outcomes.
And based on this we concluded that almost
all of these Pi's are very close to half.
And now suppose you said, look at
this fourth person, they got two nos.
What do you suppose their
true probability is?
What do you think p sub 4 is?
Well, now their argument would be,
look almost all of the Pi's are half, so
I think p sub 4 is probably
very close to a half.
And on average, this will be very good.
We will get extremely low average error
over our estimates of all the people.
And this is pretty surprising, right?
So if you think about what's
going on here we're estimating
P sub 4 more accurately than
empirical distribution.
Based on using information about
the independent random variables
corresponding to everybody
else's coin tosses.
So we're estimating p4,
not just based upon the tosses of the coin
that land heads is called op4, but
also based upon the probability of
it landing hands of all these other
independent A random variable
corresponding to different people,
this is pretty surprising.
So you might wonder to what extent have
I cherry picked the special settings,
where exactly n over 4, the people
answered yes, yes, no, no, and so on.
So it turns out that even in
the worst case no matter what
the set of underlying Pi's are you can
accurately learn the set of Pi's to
average our epsilon using only 1 over
epsilon samples from each individual.
Only 1 over epsilon opposite of each coin.
Again as opposed to if you were to
naively use the empirical estimate.
Which you do require a 1 over epsilon
squared tosses of each point.
So this is a very simple setting.
We're just trying to estimate
the steps of biases of coins
that rises in many settings, very useful.
But there are lots of more
A higher level analogue
to the setting which we're considering and
which we are thinking about now.
So there are these more
complex distributions.
So instead of just each
person having one coin,
imagine each person has something
that happens as probability p sub i,
something else that might happen
as probability q sub i, and so on.
So maybe, each person corresponds
to a visit or to a website.
P sub i is whether they buy an item,
Q sub i is whether they end up
asking for
something on the help page and so on.
So maybe, there are these more
complicated distributions,
to what extent can we get
an analogous results for these.
You might also wonder how you can leverage
additional structure to the problem to be
able to do even better.
So these are some avenues that
we're currently thinking about.
So just to summarize, the punch lines
of some of the first part of the talk.
So even with very little
data from each person
We can accurately recover the stats or
population
of distributions by leveraging the fact
that we have data from lots of people.
And as we saw, so in many cases, we can
then use this information to go back and
improve our estimates of
individual people's distributions.
This is the example where
first we concluded that
almost all of the p sub bias
must be very close to half and
then we go back and say well the fourth
person even though the empirical estimate
looks like they're a probability of
0 their piece is also probably half.
And you can do this as a special case
as what's known as Stein's Phenomena.
So this is named after
the late Charles Stein who was
a statistician at Stanford and
passed away a couple months ago.
He was the first one who noticed that you
can actually improve estimates of some
parameters based on observing
independent random variables.
So even though I'm trying to estimate For
the fourth person's probability,
I can improve my estimates of this,
on average, if I look at these
other independent random variables.
So now we'll transition into the second
part where we'll talk about how to
accurately estimate properties of
the unseen portion of a distribution.
So before I go on, let me stress that all
of the techniques that I'm talking about
are ways of cleaning up the empirical
distribution of the samples, and
these are ways of cleaning up
the empirical distribution
without making any prior assumptions
on the distribution in question.
So we're doing this based
purely on an understanding
Of how the randomness from
the sampling process ends up,
in some sense, noising up the empirical
distribution of what we see.
Okay, so in the second portion, We'll be
talking about settings where we're given
independent draws from some
distribution over a discrete support.
So think about it as we're sampling
species of fish from some population.
So we are independently
drawing fish from an ocean,
and we should think about this
as we're sampling each fish with
probability proportional to
the probability of that fish in the ocean.
Okay, so in this example, we drew six
fish, and we saw three different species.
What can we hope to say about
the underlying distribution of fish?
Well, the empirical distribution of
the sample, this is the maximum likelihood
distribution that maximizes likelihood
of drawing exactly what we observed.
However, it does not capture the
unobserved portion of the distribution.
So in this case,
we saw three different species of fish.
Maybe there's a fourth species or
a fifth species of fish in the ocean.
The empirical distribution does
not account for this at all.
So there are a few natural questions.
So one is,
what could we even hope to infer
about the unobserved portion
of the distribution?
Can we hope to say anything about it?
As we'll see the answer is yes.
We can actually say very
nuanced things about this.
And the second point is well,
how can these instances about unobserved
proportion of the distribution
yield better estimates for
aspects of a distribution
that we care about.
Suppose you want to estimate
the entropy of the distribution or
other properties of it.
How can we leverage a better understanding
of the unobserved portion to improve these
estimates over just
the empirical estimates?
So in some sense the motivation for
my work, or the inspiration for my work on
these problems goes back to very early
work of R.A. Fisher, and Allen Turing
who are respectively the godfathers of
modern statistics and computer science.
So in the case of Fisher, he was given
this data of a biologist named Corbet.
So Corbet spent a year in the Malaysian
jungle in the 1940s collecting
butterflies.
And this chart at the bottom of the page,
this is Corbet's Butterfly Data.
So what does this represent?
Well, the left-most spike represents
the fact that, while he was in Malaysia,
he discovered or
he caught 110 species of butterflies.
And of these 110 species of butterflies,
he only ever saw individuals from them,
exactly once.
The second spike represents
the fact that there were 75 species
of butterflies that he
caught exactly twice.
The third spike represents the fact
that were something like 45 species
of butterflies that he caught three
times in his year in Malaysia.
And way off on the right of the plot,
which is cut off.
Yes, there's the common ground moth, and
you probably caught that 1,000 times.
And that corresponds to
a spike of height 1,
representing the fact that there's
1 species that he saw 1,000 times.
So this would be a spike at
location 1,000 of height 1.
So while he was there he discovered
something like 230 species of butterflies.
So he sent his data to Ari Fisher,
who's the big statistician of the time,
and he said listen.
I'm thinking about staying for
another year in the jungle,
can you tell me how many new
species you think I would discover
if I catch butterflies at the same
rate as I did during my first year.
And it actually turns out that there is
a extremely accurate estimate for this.
So, if you compute this alternating sum.
So, take the total number of
species you've seen exactly once,
subtract the number of species you've
observed twice, add the number of species
you've seen three times, subtract
the number you've seen four times.
Compute this alternating sum.
And this gives an essentially
unbiased estimate
of the total number of new species
you would expect to discover
in the same time period if you're
collecting butterflies at the same rate.
And again, this assumes nothing other
than the fact that you're collecting
butterflies at the same rate and
that the underlying distribution
of butterflies is fixed.
So this is pretty surprising right,
we are accurately saying something about
the unobserved portion
of the distribution.
So at roughly the same
time Alan Turing and I.J.
Good were working at Bletchley Park
on the British World War II effort.
They were interested in
estimating similar things.
So they wanted to estimate,
what's the probability that the next
German enigma machine, ciphertext, it
didn't use ciphertext that we hadn't seen.
Differently, in Corbet's language, this is
estimating the probability that the next
butterfly that he catches is a new
species that he hasn't seen.
A third way of stating this,
if you are trying to estimate
the total probability math in the true
distribution that consistent to mean
elements that you haven't observed yet.
So this is the missing math in other
words, the math in the true distribution
which is missing completely from
the empirical distribution.
And it turns out that there's
a very simple estimate for
this, an essentially unbiased estimate for
this missing math.
And this is now known as the Good–Turing
frequency estimation scheme.
This says look at the total number of
domain elements that you've seen exactly
once, divide it by your sample size,
and this tells you a good estimate for
the probability that the next
domain element you see is new.
So if you think about this.
What does this mean?
Well, this means, if you want to know,
what's the probability that the next
song you hear on the radio is a new
song you've never heard before.
Well, think back.
Count the total number of songs you've
heard exactly once in your life.
Divide that by the number of
songs you've heard, in total.
And this gives you a estimate for
the probability you'll be surprised
with the next song you hear.
Okay and this makes sense.
If in general you were surprised by 3% of
the songs you hear, the probability you're
going to be surprised by the next
song you hear is probably 3%.
Okay so Turing and
Fisher give extremely accurate estimates,
in some sense of a single parameter of
the unseen portion of the distribution.
So, how much more can
we hope to understand?
So, in our results we're actually going
to be able to recover estimates of
the structure of the unseen portions.
Not just estimate of the total amount of
mass, but actually estimates of the number
of unseen elements that arise
with different probabilities.
So what is this good for?
Well one can answer questions
in the following form.
One can ask questions like,
what's the value of collecting more data?
If we were to collect
a hundred times more data,
how many more domain elements
are we likely to observe?
Or we could ask questions like, how much
data is necessary before actually we
are likely to see 99.9% of the phenomena
to rise in the given distribution?
So this latter question
might be relevant for
assessing like autonomous vehicles
where you want to know how much more
do we need to revise these
things until we actually have
a good coverage over the sort of events
that arrive when you're driving?
And there are a number of more
scientific reasons why you might care
about understanding the structure
of the unseen portions,
including understanding properties
of the unseen in humans.
And I'll give some concrete examples of
that towards the end of this portion.
Okay, so how can we do this?
Well, let's begin with just a thought
experiment, suppose we actually take 100
million samples, we draw 100 million
independent draws from some distribution.
And suppose we see about one
million domain elements, and
each element, each domain element,
we see roughly 100 times.
And if you were to look at
a histogram of the frequencies,
suppose we see something like this.
So again, what does this plot represent?
Well the big spike at 100 represents
the fact that there are lots and lots
of domain elements that we see roughly
100 times, we see exactly 100 times.
And yes there's some domain elements
that we only see 80 times or 90 times,
and some domain elements that we see 120,
or 130 times.
This is a, you can think of this as
a histogram of the histogram of the data.
So, this is a histogram
of the frequencies.
Suppose someone asks you, well,
what distribution do you think
these samples were drawn from?
In other words, if someone said hey,
look at this one domain element.
We observed it 130 times.
What do you think its true probability is?
Would you answer?
Well the empirical probability is
130 divided by the sample size,
so 130 divided by 100M.
Or Would you do something else?
So I claim that actually, based on no
prior assumptions on the distribution,
only an understanding of the mapping
from a true distribution to an empirical
distribution, we can accurately
de-noise this distribution,
de-noise this empirical distribution.
And conclude that the true distribution
from which these samples were drawn is
probably extremely close to a uniform
distribution over a million domain
elements.
So why is this the case?
Well, suppose the true distribution
actually were a uniform distribution over
a million domain elements.
If we had drawn the 100
million samples from this,
we would've seen something
extremely similar to this picture.
Most things we see roughly 100 times,
some things we see more,
some things we see less.
And the standard deviation and the number
of times we see different elements
could be roughly ten, and
it would roughly look like this picture.
If the true distribution had any
significant variance in the probabilities,
then after you take into account,
the extra sampling noise that's added just
from the sampling process, I claim we
would end up seeing this histogram that's
even faster, that has even more variance.
One way of thinking about this is
that the mapping from the true
distribution to the empirical distribution
can be almost thought of as
a sort of convolution operator.
Something that can add noise and
sneers out the probabilities.
And the question is just to what
extent can you de-convolve?
Can you de-noise?
Can you remove the effect
of the sampling noise?
In this case, I claim you can do it
very robustly and very accurately.
And what does this mean?
Well, this means that someone comes and
says, hey,
this element was observed 130 times,
what do you think its true probability is?
You can safely say, well, yes,
I know this guy was observed 130 times and
this other domain element
was only observed 80 times.
But I think that actually, the true
probabilities of them are probably almost
the same and
probably equal to just one over a million.
Just like almost all these other elements,
okay?
So this is an analog of the reasoning
that we did in the first part.
Okay, so we can do some de-noising.
And one question is, well,
how far can we push this?
So let's just continue trying to
do this kind of mental experiment.
So suppose we have a histogram based on k
samples, and we see something like this.
Well, we'd say this looks like maybe it
corresponds to uniform distribution over k
over 100 elements.
This is what we just did.
Why?
Because if the true distribution had any
significant variance in the probabilities,
we would expect to see something
slightly from what we see.
Of course, proving that might be
difficult, but that's the reason.
Okay, let's look at another example.
Suppose this is actually a histogram
based on 10,000 samples drawn from some
distribution.
What distribution do you
think this is drawn from?
Well, you might recognize that this kind
of looks like a Poisson distribution of
expectation five.
So you could argue that, well, seeing this
is consistent with having drawn these
10,000 samples from a uniform
distribution over 2,000 elements.
And in this case you'd be right.
This histogram was made by
me sampling 10,000 things in
that lab from a uniform
distribution over 2,000 elements.
How far can we push this?
Well, you might recognize that this is
a Poisson distribution of expectation two
and think that maybe this corresponds to
a uniform distribution over support size
10,000 divided by 2 over
support size 5,000.
And you would be correct.
Maybe this corresponds to a uniform
distribution over 10,000 elements.
Maybe this is the uniform
distribution over 20,000 elements.
distribution over 50,000 elements.
So how far can we push this?
So at this point, what we're claiming
is actually pretty impressive.
So, we have a histogram,
we have data based on 10,000 samples.
We've only seen 9,000
distinct domain elements.
And yet, we're claiming we can reason that
the reason this data was probably drawn
from some distribution supported
on 50,000 domain elements.
And that this distribution is
probably extremely close to uniform.
So we haven't seen most of these domain
elements that we're actually claiming that
we can accurately describe roughly
how many of them they are and
roughly their true probability.
So the natural question is,
well, how general and
how far can this reasoning be pushed?
So in all of these examples, we were
thinking about uniform distributions.
And the only reason we're thinking
about uniform distributions is because
it's easier to do our mental
calculations on them.
So what can we say about non-uniform
distributions and how can we actually
make this approach rigorous and
turn this into an actual algorithm?
So if you think about what we were doing,
we were basically asking what distribution
has expected histogram similar to
the observed histogram of the samples.
And it turns out that you can write this
problem, you can write this problem we
we're solving in our heads on
the previous slide, as a linear program.
So I won't explain exactly
what this linear program is.
But it basically just asks,
find me a distribution with
expected histogram that's
close to the observed one.
Why did it end up being a linear program?
Well, because we only care
about expectations and
linearity of expectations,
that's where it comes from.
But I won't go into the details.
So what does the algorithm do?
Well, it finds one of these
distributions via linear programming.
And this linear program basically
just defines a feasible region of
distributions which are all
consistent with the observation.
Of course, the technical
challenge is then to argue about
the diameter of this feasible region
shrinks as our sample size grows.
So we have some concrete technical
results regarding this, which,
they're tight to constant factor.
And I just wanted to give you a flavor
of what these sorts of things say.
So given n independent draws
from some unknown distribution,
we can recover the sets of probabilities,
p sub i.
As well as an empirical distribution
would, if the empirical distribution
would've been based on an extra
logarithmic factor more samples.
So two points.
So the first is we are only recovering
the sets of probabilities p sub i.
We're not recovering
the underlying domain.
So think of it this way.
So suppose you go fishing,
you catch lots of fish.
We're going to recover a set of
probabilities of the species.
Although if you haven't caught any tuna,
I'm not going to say,
there must be a tuna in the ocean.
Okay, so
I'm not going to label the domain.
I'm just going to try to recover
the sets of probabilities.
So one corollary of this result, which is
maybe easier to understand and easier to
parse, is for a given n independent draws
from some distribution, you can accurately
estimate the number of new elements
that you would see in a larger sample.
And you can do this for samples of size
up to O(n log n) in the worst case.
So in most practical settings,
we seem to be able to
accurately infer the number of new things
we'll see from much, much larger samples.
But this is the best we can do
in the worst case sense, and
there's matching lower information
theoretical lower bound
I wanted to give a quick
practical application of this.
So this is in joint work with James Zou
and this appeared Nature Communications.
So currently we have 60,000 genomes
of healthy individuals that
have been sequenced.
So one natural question is, what's
the value in sequencing larger cohorts?
So say we sequence half a million
a people, two million people,
ten million people,
what's the value in this?
How many more new medically relevant
mutations are we likely to see if
we sequence more people?
So applying the linear programming
based algorithm from two slides ago,
we can do the following
sort of validation.
So yes, we have 60,000 genomes
of healthy individuals,
suppose we only looked at 6,000 of them.
And based on those 6,000 we tried to
estimate how many new mutations of
a certain medically relevant type we
would be likely to see if we actually had
60,000 genomes.
So based on the first 6,000 genomes we
can predict how many new things we would
have seen, given more genomes.
And the blue line is our predictions.
The red line is the ground truth, because
we do actually have 60,000 genomes.
And then the light blue area
corresponds to one standard deviation
over different choices of the 6,000
size cohort out of the 60,000 genomes.
So we're doing quite well.
So then the fun part is to say well,
we do actually have 60,000 genomes,
what would we be likely to see,
if we sequenced a quarter of a million or
half a million more people?
So just to provide a tiny bit
of background on this, so
here we are looking at
loss-of-function mutations.
So a loss-of-function mutation is a
mutation which will break that given gene.
So on average, most healthy
people have maybe one or one and
half loss-of- function mutations,
and it's not a big deal.
So one thing people are doing at the
Stanford Hospital now, if you come in and
you're very sick, it's usually children
who have very strange symptoms and
it's not clear what's wrong with them.
The people at the hospital start by
just sequencing their genome and
looking for loss-of-function mutations.
So they ask are there
any mutations which we
know break a given gene in this patient?
And then what do they do?
For each of these broken genes, they ask,
in this cohort of 60,000 healthy
individuals, were there any healthy
individuals who also had this broken gene?
And if the answer is yes,
there are lots of healthy people that
also has this broken gene, then they say,
well this broken gene probably isn't
causing this, isn't causing them sickness.
If none of the healthy people
have this broken gene,
then they say maybe this broken gene
is what's causing the sickness and
then they try to figure out
what does this gene do?
Maybe it codes for some protein,
maybe you can synthesize this protein and
inject it into the patient, and
then the patient gets better.
Of course we have 20,000 genes,
we only have 60,000 genomes
healthy people's genomes.
So there are lots of genes which might be
okay to break which we haven't observed.
And this plot basically tells us how many
more individuals would we need to sequence
in other to get a pretty good
coverage over the genes for
which it's okay to have
broken in a healthy person.
So this is a real value setting and
we're going to be trying to
estimate the covariance matrix.
And this is joint work with Weihao Kong.
So suppose we have an n independent draws
from some d dimensional distribution.
A natural question is to understand how
large must n be, what must our sample
size be, in order to understand
the structure of the distribution?
And one question is, well,
if we have too little data to actually
find the structure, then maybe we're not
going to be given enough information to
accurately return top principal components
or eigenvectors of our distribution.
Can we still say whether or not there
is structure in the distribution?
So can you say something like listen, I
don't have enough distribution to, sorry,
I don't have enough data,
To tell you which
low dimensional space your
distribution lies in,
though I do know that it lies
in some low dimensional space.
Okay, so
this is kind of a thought experiment.
Suppose I have my data consisting
of 1,000 independent draws from
some 1,000 dimensional
Gaussian distribution.
And the Gaussian distribution
has mean zero, and
I'm not sure what the covariance is.
And if you were to look at
a histogram of the eigenvalues,
of the empirical covariance of the data,
so, again you have a 1,000 data points,
you just look at the covariance
of these data and you look and
you ask how many directions are there that
look like there are lots of variance?
And you plot this histogram,
suppose this is what you see.
So what does this mean?
This means that well, there are lots of
directions that have almost no variance,
that's the big spike at the left.
And there are a few directions that
have variants four and three and so on.
Okay, so you have your data,
it looks like there's lots of directions.
It looks like there are 200
directions with very little variance,
a couple of directions with big variance.
And now suppose someone asks you,
what was the true covariance structure
of this underlying distribution?
Well, I claim that in this case the
empirical eigenvalues are very misleading.
And in fact, the data was
generated by taking 1,000 samples
from an identity covariance Gaussian.
So this means that all of
the directions have the same variance.
However, because we only had 1,000 samples
from our 1,000 dimensional distribution,
just due to the randomness,
it looks like there's
some directions with big variance and
some some directions with small variance.
If you were to run this experiment again,
if you were to take another thousand
samples from the same Gaussian, and plot
the eigenvalues of empirical covariance,
you would get this exact same plot again.
And if I kept doing this you would keep
getting a plot very similar to this.
So now, suppose a year later,
some doctor came up to you and said hey,
I got this new data.
I'm looking at the covariance structure in
varied mutations or
some medically important something or
other, and
this is my covariance structure.
Look, there are a bunch of interesting,
there are a bunch of interesting
relationships that have this big variance.
What would you say?
You say I remember this spot,
I know this curve.
This curve actually is the curve that
arises when you have no structure,
there are no interesting
relationships in the data,
you just have too small of a sample size.
So I claim that every time you see a plot
of this, a plot that looks like this,
reflecting the eigenvalues of an empirical
programming matrix, you can safely
conclude that actually there's no
structure in the underlying distribution.
Okay, so one question is, suppose you
actually do look at this histogram of
eigenvalues of an empirical covariance and
it looks something different than this.
To what extent can you then de-noise
this and reveal the true covariant
structure of the distribution and
while you can apply.
The same mindset as we did earlier,
but using very different techniques
to say things about this.
So maybe I'll skip the formal.
Yeah, I'll skip the formal statement.
So, just to conclude with
a few final thoughts.
So, we discussed two, and
maybe three different settings.
And in all three of these settings,
the underlying approaches are following.
We first understood the mapping
from the underlying distribution to
the empirical distribution.
And then the kind of crux of
what we were actually doing,
which is try to invert this mapping.
To say suppose we actually saw
this empirical distribution,
what does this tell us about
the true distribution underlying it?
So we're inverting this kind of mapping
from the truth to the empirical.
And in these three different settings,
it yielded, in some sense,
pretty surprising results that actually
lead to meaningful algorithms.
Okay so if you get nothing else from
this talk, I hope you at least remember
that well in many settings, even when
the empirical distribution is misleading,
you can still often extract
surprisingly accurate information.
And the second point that there
are many extremely basic settings.
Settings that you would have thought
statisticians maybe might have
understood a century ago,
that we still don't understand.
So there's much room for future research
about this intersection of algorithms and
statistics and
information theory in learning.
So thank you.
So I guess now maybe we'll open it up for
questions.
So I guess there are a few
questions that I wanted to address.
So there was one question from Andre Coke,
who asked how do you know that
the unseen distribution law is uniform?
So this corresponds to
the second portion of the talk.
This was where we did
this thought experiment.
Starting with, suppose you have 100
million samples, and you happen to have
seen roughly 1 million domain elements,
each observed roughly 100 times.
So, in this kind of thought experiment,
it did turn out that the unseen
distribution law was uniform.
So all of these were actually
uniform distributions.
And so the question is,
how do we know this?
And well, the claim is,
if your work has [INAUDIBLE] that actually
looked like this data that I
was hypothetically giving, you
can actually robustly conclude that the
true underlying distribution is uniform.
The results apply much more generally.
So even if the true underlying
distribution isn't uniform,
this linear programming approach
to inferring the underlying
structure will actually give you, or
will accurately tell you the structure.
Even if the underlying
distribution is not uniform.
The point in these examples was more
just to give a concrete example that's
somehow simple enough that we
can actually think about it.
But the underlying techniques
work more generally.
And this is actually a similar response
applies to some of the earlier
questions about the kind of warm up,
the first part at the talk which asks,
are we assuming that the individuals
are identical and independent?
The answer is, well we're assuming
they're independent, but not identical.
So maybe some of the people
have larger probabilities,
some of them have smaller probabilities.
And we would actually be able to infer
the underlying set of these probabilities,
even if they are not all the same.
And when I say we can infer the set of
probabilities, again, to start with,
we're not trying to figure out
each person's probability.
So I don't want to know,
if someone just tosses a coin twice,
I maybe will never know what
their true probability is.
But I'll infer, roughly, how many people
have probabilities 0.4, how many people
have probability of roughly 0.5, how many
people have a probability of roughly 0.6.
Okay, so I guess one other question,
that's actually a really,
really nice question, from Yan Gokowski.
So they ask well, what, if any, is the
relationship between these techniques, and
deconvolution approaches,
such as used in signal processing?
So this is a very good question.
If you think about what the mapping is
between kind of a true distribution and
the empirical distribution,
in many cases this does look like
you're convolving the true structure of
the distribution by some noise operator
to yield the empirical distribution.
So for example, if we have a uniform
distribution over a million elements and
then we take 100 million
samples from this,
the empirical frequencies will kind of
look like we convolved this big spike
of uniform distribution by some
sort of Gaussian-type distribution.
And in that sense,
you can almost view these techniques
as deconvolving to remove
the effects of sampling, basically.
From a technical perspective,
this is actually a little different.
So usually when you
think of convolution and
deconvolution, you have a fixed kernel.
In this case the mapping from the true
distribution to the empirical
distribution, it's not
actually convolusion,
even though it's some kind of blurring
operator, but you have a much more
complicated blurrning operator which
makes it in general harder to deconvolve.
So, particularly in the last setting
that I had discussed where you have
some distribution of empirical Eigen
values of the covariance matrix.
It becomes very clear that the mapping
from the true structure of the geometric
distribution, the true Eigen values and
the covariance, the empirical thing.
It's not just a convolution, it's some
very strange kind of noise operator that
behaves very differently for
the big Eigen vectors and the small ones.
And so that's where kind of
the technical difficulty comes in.
That intuitively you want to do
this denoising, deconvolution,
but it's not actually
a clean deconvolution.
Okay so, sorry, so the one of
the questions asked, do I have an example
of eigenvalue distribution for covariance
matrix with meaningful structure.
So I do have some thoughts I can show.
So each of these plots corresponds to the,
you can think of this as
the cumulative distribution function
of the eigenvalues of a distribution.
So what does this actually mean?
So the blue line is corresponding
to the true distribution.
And this means that well half of the
eigenvalues are one of the covariants and
half of them are two.
What does this mean?
This means that we have some
high dimensional distribution.
And half of the direction to variance one,
half of the direction to variance two.
If you were to look at
the empirical covariance matrix.
The very light blue lines
that look like these curves,
this represents the eigenvalues of
the empirical covariance matrix.
So in particular if you have relatively
few samples, the directions of variance 1,
the directions of variance 2 all just
get blurred together and it looks like
some directions to variance 1.5,
some directions to variance 0.3 and so on.
Using this sort of, I guess you can almost
think of it as a de-convolution approach.
Even when the number of samples is linear
or slightly smaller than the dimension,
we can actually recover the underlying
structure, namely that there are half
the dimensions have variance one then
half the dimensions have variance two.
And we have other examples
of cases like this
where there is actually structure in
the underlying covariance matrix.
>> So maybe, Greg,
now that we're at the top of the hour,
you can take one more question?
>> Okay, so, yeah, so
I guess I'll finish with a slightly
more kind of general question.
So this question's from
Orlando Tucker who asked,
how important is this information in
machine learning and deep learning?
So this is a good question.
So most of the work I do kind of
focuses on fundamental kind of
questions that have more
of a theoretical nature.
And I guess my answer
is twofold.
So looking forward, at some point,
I do think if we want progress in machine
learning, deep learning to continue at the
rate that it has, we will actually need to
start thinking about how do you get more
information from the data than currently.
So deep learning has done a lot of great
things, but it is extremely data hungry.
So you really do need to
give it a lot of data.
And if you think about it, what's the
chance that we're going to get an extra
factor of 1,000 to 10,000
more good text data?
Not great.
We already have all of Wikipedia,
finding an extra factor
of 10,000 more good data,
it doesn't seem like we
should go down that path.
Instead it seems like we should try to
figure out how to get more from the data
we have.
I guess from a very concrete standpoint,
so
one can plug in some of these techniques
kind of below the deep learning or
more high level machine
learning portions of a system.
So one can these sorts of techniques
to come out correct empirical
distributions a little bit and then hand
them off to these higher level systems.
And also I guess one dimension that there
is, yes there's a lot of kind of higher
level machine learning stuff, but there's
also need to actually concretely get
information about the value of collecting
more data and questions like this.
So one thing I'm starting to think about
is how do you use these ideas together
with higher level machine learning things
to ask if you were to take ten times more
data how would the performance of your
systems improve and that sort of thing.
So at least some of the ideas can
work nicely in conjunction with
these machine learning and
deep learning approaches.
So thank you.
>> Great, so thank you, Greg for
a wonderful presentation and
for taking time to answer some
of our attendee questions.
And we want to thank you for
taking the time to attend today.
And hopefully we'll see
you at our next webinar.
Have a great day.